sometimes the actors who play the bad
guys we love to hate have to pass the
role to someone else maybe it's because
of behind-the-scenes drama well perhaps
it's because of busy schedules here are
the real reasons these super villain
actors were replaced Frank Gorshin
played the quizzing villain the Riddler
in the sixties Batman series gorshins
masked trickster remained one of the
most well loved villains of the series
and even Mark Hamill named him as one of
these influences for his work on the
Joker is Riddler's like one of my
favorite comic book villains of all time
I love Frank Gorshin yet in Batman
second season gawssian inexplicably
disappeared for two episodes and was
replaced by John Astin who's best known
as Gomez Adams from The Addams Family
they were Astin's only appearances as
the brain-teasing bad guy and caution
eventually returned to the role there
are different stories about why the
brief hiccup in casting happened
gorshins version was that he had a
nightclub appearance commitment he
couldn't get out of that conflicted with
the shooting schedule but Batman
producer William Dozier claimed that
gorshins talent agency demanded more
money for the actors appearances on the
show than its budget could bear - of
Marvel's most vicious rivals of
Wolverine and Victor Creed aka
Sabretooth fans got a tiny piece of that
rivalry on the big screen in 2000 x-men
when retired professional wrestler Tyler
Mane played Sabretooth as part of
Magneto's Brotherhood he doesn't say
much but he gets a couple of good throw
downs with Hugh Jackman's Logan but when
it was time to give Logan his first solo
flick with 2009 x-men origins Wolverine
Mane was nowhere to be seen
instead it was Liev Schreiber playing
the savage mutant speaking to The
Hollywood Reporter in 2017 Mane said he
didn't get to play saboteurs in the
prequel because the filmmakers wanted
someone who looked more like Jackman the
wrestler explained
the storyline was them rising his
brothers and Liev and Hugh look a lot
closer in that respect so I understand I
can't say I wasn't disappointed I'd love
to get my claws back into that role but
that's Hollywood Hugo Weaving played the
villainous Red Skull in 2011's Captain
America the First Avenger but when the
character surprised audiences seven
years later by showing up in Avengers
infinity war there was another actor
under all the prosthetics in order to
take the stone you must lose that which
you love while the accent and the voice
may have sounded right it was actually a
skilled impression by Walking Dead actor
Ross Marquand not waving weavings
decision to sit this one out was hardly
surprising since the actor told Collider
in 2012 that he had no intention of
reprising the Marvel role while
acknowledging that he'd signed a multi
picture contract with Marvel he said he
didn't think Marvel would try to force
the matter if he said no but it turns
out that weaving may have been willing
to return if Marvel had honored the
terms of his contract he told time out
in 2020 that Marvel had tried to
negotiate a lower rate for infinity war
and its sequel Avengers endgame then was
promised in his original contract as a
result weaving bowed out opening the
door for Marquand the first actress to
play
Batman's feline antagonist Catwoman in
the sixties TV series was julie newmar
who actually returned to the role in two
recent animated features 2016's batman
return of the caped crusaders and the
following years Batman vs two-face
unfortunately when it came time to film
the 1966 Batman movie with the cast of
the TV show Newmar was shooting the soon
to be abandoned comedy Monsieur the cook
she was replaced for the film by Lee
Meriwether
although Newmar continued playing the
character on the show for Batman's third
and final season yuuma left the series
to make the Western McKenna's gold an
actress and singer Eartha Kitt took up
the role of
Gotham's top cat burglar because kit was
african-american it was deemed too
controversial at the time for her and
Batman to keep teasing each other so
their romantic connection unfortunately
disappeared while he never got any acid
thrown on him fans were guessing that
attorneys two-faced might eventually be
in the cards for Billy Dee Williams when
he played Harvey Dent in 1989's Batman
in that film debt had just become bottom
city's new district attorney and hadn't
yet suffered the catastrophic injury
that would prompt his shift from Batman
a lie to super villain for your knife
pleasure however at the 2017 Wizard
World Nashville comic-con Williams told
fans that his chance to play two-face
ended when director Joel Schumacher took
the reins from Tim Burton on Batman
Forever Williams explained I had hoped
that I would have done two-face but it
changed hands before then and I think
Schumacher got involved so they took a
different direction with that however
Williams did eventually get to play
two-faced in a different format in 2017
he voiced the iconic villain in the Lego
Batman movie the mid-credits scene of
2012's the Avengers briefly introduced
movie audiences to Thanos
but it wasn't until Avengers infinity
war that the villain finally became the
focus of the main story the Thanos we
met in the Avengers big credit scene
isn't the same guy who plays the mad
Titan in the rest of the Infinity Saga
True Blood actor Damian Poitier played
to Thanos at the end of the Avengers but
there was no drama behind the decision
to replace him in the MCU Avengers
director Joss Whedon admitted he really
wasn't sure exactly what to do with
Thanos after the Avengers and playing
there was no real long-term plan when
Portier
was cast by the time the characters came
around again in 2014's guardians of the
galaxy Marvel had a clearer idea of
Thanos trajectory in the MCU and Josh
Brolin was cast in the role as Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige put it
Brolin could be Thanos without in
affects he has that kind of face and
that kind of gravitas
inevitable in 2009 the video game Batman
Arkham Asylum was released and quickly
earned the reputation as one of the best
superhero
video games ever one of the games
highlights was the return of voice
actors from the popular batman the
animated series television show most
notably Kevin Conroy as Batman and Mark
Hamill as the Joker look at all this new
security as the guy supposed to break
out of here Conroy and Hamill would lend
their voices to follow-ups like Arkham
City Arkham Knight and Arkham via the
both were missing from the 2013 prequel
game Batman Arkham origins instead of
Hamill the Clown Prince of Crime was
voiced by Troy Baker an official reason
has never been offered for Hamill's
absence from Arkham origins but we know
a couple of likely contributing factors
first while he would eventually do
Joker's voice again for other games as
well as the 2016 animated adaptation
Batman The Killing Joke Hamill told IGN
in 2012 he had no intention of ever
voicing the Joker again second unlike
the first two Arkham games which were
developed by Rocksteady Arkham origins
was developed by WB Montreal which
reportedly couldn't spare as big of a
budget check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
adaptations are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one